[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Ryan Leaf the
aforementioned college football NFL
analyst for Westwood one NFL Network and
the number two overall pick by the
Chargers
1998 draft the David teer fine for
throwing a drink on some Jacksonville
Jaguar fans
$300,000 Ryan Leaf says
what great I mean it's a what is that
like a tip jar for him is that enough I
mean I don't I don't know I mean this
the behavior that you could control from
a a billionaire owner who seemly shown
everybody that you know he has uh real
control issues I think and that was
showcased I don't know $300,000 for a
guy who's a billionaire in terms of what
that is means anything to him I mean he
might find that in his cushions of his
couch so well why I said suspend him
like don't let him go to a game yeah cuz
that's the value there you know Steve
Balmer is one of the richest men on the
planet he gets to go to Clipper games
you know take away that that the item
that team then I think that's more
painful give him an embarrassing timeout
an NFL timeout send him to his room and
say you can't go for the last game of
this regular season yeah I mean that's
that's the job of the commissioner if
the commissioner wasn't intimately
intimately involved with the 32 owners
or 31 owners you know it's it's he works
for them so it's got to be incredibly
odd for the your employee essentially to
turn around and go I'm going to find you
30 $300,000 for for your uh
indiscretions it's just an odd odd
relationship in in general it's a
privately run company and it's weird to
that I wonder how that money turns
around and comes back to to him some way
somehow it's true uh Bryce young how
would you assess what like if you're
looking at handicapping him as an
analyst and a former quarterback what
what would you say to Carolina fans I
I'd say uh usually you have to see how a
player is going to react right when you
go through adversity like that when
people are tossing the bust word at you
and saying you're a failure and all
those things how are you
emotionally um mature enough to deal
with it and I think Bryce young is an
incredibly mature emotional young man I
really do so I don't have any fear in
him being able to weather it and doing
well and getting better in year two
regardless of who is at the helm my only
fear is the team is awful I mean there's
no skill position players they have not
added to it they would have the number
one overall pick if they didn't trade it
away to the Chicago Bears so that's my
bigger issue this when you when you get
drafted first or second or third overall
you're going to a bad team period and
you have to have I would say
generational um ability to to change the
culture and the environment of a
football team it's just it's rare you
got Joe burrow in Cincinnati you got
pton Manning in Indianapolis it's just a
an individual that can walk into a
building and he can change the
environment that he's in and that is
incredibly difficult when you don't have
the skill position players and that's
where they're lacking right now they
don't have the draft picks they don't
have the money I don't know if any coach
worth his Merit really wants to go there
because of the ownership somebody's
going to take it because he's going to
get paid you know generational wealth
and so it's it's a tough spot it was
tough sledding I think CJ stad probably
is thinking his lucky stars that he
wasn't the first overall pick a year ago
if I said to David teer you could redo
number one overall pick well I think
that uh from what I heard from it it was
uh uh it was his influence on on Bryce
young but let's say I said this to it
privately publicly he can't say well
take CJ St but but if I said you could
redo this I I I have a question about
that I have a question around whether CJ
strad in that Carolina Panthers uniform
is any better than what Bryce young has
been this year that's fair it's the team
aspect of things I understand the
quarterback gets so much of the
recognition both good and both bad when
things go right or wrong but it is a
team game it is the Ultimate Team game
if all 11 aren't functioning on the same
level every single week it's not going
to be successful and everything gets
laid at the feet of the quarterback I
really have a problem with the idea that
if you put CJ strad in Carolina they
would be uh you know they'd be buying
for the playoffs in the NFC South right
now yeah but we're making the Texans
roster sound like it's a lot better than
what it is the offensive line was
incredibly good to start the season yeah
but the skilled position if I said they
got Dalton Schultz nobody's going yes I
mean and even some of these other
receivers that kind of came out of
nowhere I don't know if you know it it
wasn't like it's Tyreek Hill and the
Chiefs you know tank was wonderful he
got in nobody knew him anybody who was
down in Houston knew him but uh because
he went to the university there I I
think that CJ stad makes players better
I think his who was a better quarterback
I had CJ strout as you know going into
the draft as my number one guy that was
that was Far and Away I thought there
was a sizable difference between the two
I thought the size was the big
difference for Bryce young in terms of
you know what he looked like in
comparison to Kyler Murray because Kyler
was such a stout guy down
downstairs um his baseball background
you know and and just the size was going
to give Bryce young a problem unless you
had an offense that really was
structured around him and then you go
and Fire the guy that he brought in to
do that and his quarterback coach you
know Midway through the year so I mean
it's been exactly how first round draft
first overall pick sometimes when they
go to bad teams and up new coach all the
things new offensive coordinator all the
things that go with that and
unfortunately uh it's going to be tied
to CJ st's success if they were to win
this weekend and go to the playoffs boy
that's even a bigger uh insult to injury
on on that draft pick how was Joe flacko
doing this I am so impressed with Joe
flacko I now hey I'll say this and I've
been coming on your show for years and
Paulie and and M mcloven back in the day
you know we go out and do do crazy
stunts right we're in New York we're
throwing the ball up into through the
window you know we can still throw it
that's never going to go away we always
will be able to throw the football what
goes away um I think the you the burst
right when you want to get out of the
pocket the burst um flexibility Mobility
all those things um but what I also
think goes away is your ability to read
things as quickly and deci but Joe never
had a burst no and he never needs one
and he doesn't now cuz he deciphers and
disseminates what goes on in the
defensive side of the football and I
think Kevin stefansky and him really
have a connection in terms of how they
see offensive played you know and
they're not afraid to let them just toss
it around like you know what was it a
few weeks ago where thre the three
interceptions plus the three touchdowns
it's it's not a sinker swim when it
comes to that they know they're going to
have good positive things and the
dismantling the Jets the other night I
mean wow that was the most points ever
or second most points ever scored by the
Browns in a first half 34 points that's
crazy to think and Joe Flaco's doing it
they they are in a really good position
because they may have they may have a
walk through uh in the AFC Wild Card
round and then they're right in the
divisional most likely against B uh I
think against Baltimore essentially
unless somebody behind him wins um and
they've won there this year so I mean
you put Joe flco and what they're doing
offensively in a position with that
defense I mean Cleveland's a real
problem in the AFC for some people I
believe
we're talking to Ryan Leaf the uh former
college quarterback uh with Washington
State gos yeah and uh in the NFL with
the
Chargers uh we're now working for
Westwood one and NFL Network you know
sometimes when you're looking at a team
you're trying to figure out just how
good they are and and at this point of
the season I don't know if I know how
good Kansas City is I don't know if I
know how good Miami is and I don't know
if I know how good Dallas is and those
are three teams that could go to the
Super Bowl yeah uh I would would argue
that I think you know more about Kansas
City you may not know who they are this
year but the pedigree the evidence there
hasn't been no evidence that Miami or
Dallas will do anything but how do you
overcome bad receivers uh well I mean we
had good receivers and they had to
overcome a bad quarterback a lot the
time but I would I would say that I
think the the game plan will do that I
think Travis Kel's got to step up I mean
he's been missing an action for the last
few weeks I think it's what six or seven
consecutive weeks without a touchdown
catch yeah but how does that happen
um playoff football is a different deal
and they know it better than anybody
it's where they live but I'm saying
Travis Kelce how do you get how are you
Mia uh how are you Mia well I think
people take uh defensive measures to to
take them away I also think that there's
been a diminishment in his athletic
ability just because of the age and the
beating he's taken over his career I do
think that is real I think you know uh
time it does feel like it's starting to
show a little bit it but I don't know if
it's ever is it that abrupt where it's
like oh my God I think so I mean it it
feels that way when I watch and
sometimes I'll see Watson making an
athletic play not Travis Kelce and I but
I think it's Kelce just out of habit it
it's uh I've called two of their games
in the last uh five weeks and so I've
seen you know they he's been open a lot
there is a a mistrust right now with
Patrick Mahomes in terms of what is
being called what he's seen and what
he's willing to go through through a
progression I mean in that Raiders game
he had a ton of guys that were open he
just doesn't have the same confidence to
Let It Go like he has in the years past
and not much has changed in terms of the
wide receiver position from last year to
this year Juju Smith Schuster was really
the only difference yeah in all of this
and so that's the big thing for me I
don't I don't worry too much about
Kansas City in the playoffs I think they
host uh they're going to host the first
round most likely against well I think I
think the bills going to Miami and win
so that means that Miami is going to go
to Kansas City in week one of the AFC
wild card weekend and I I don't think
Miami is able to go to the cold and get
the wind there all of that so I think
you go to a divisional round you most
likely go to the bills and uh and you
just don't know I have more faith in
Kansas City Andy Reid Patrick Holmes all
that because of their past and until
somebody actually steps up and does it
I'm not going to um I'm not going to uh
not ride with them when they comes to
the playoff time all right you have to
throw it to one of these guys yeah Game
On The Line Game On the Line
Tony or Valdez scanley
uh cadarius Tony because I'll probably
throw it to him behind the line of
scrimmage than his athletic ability can
do it msv for me has just been uh just
missing an action down the field um
wherever he's at he has how do you
forget how to catch a
football I I don't think you forget how
to catch a football I think if you look
at the amount of drops that have that
have happened um it isn't it isn't a
dramatic amount Justin Watson's the one
that leads the team in leads the league
I think in in drop passes so that's the
guy you got to be looking at more he's
unfortunately uh msv has been um on the
field and taken more snaps than anybody
else and just isn't being targeted
enough because of the things that people
are speculating and what Patrick Mahomes
has to see you can go back and look at
some of the games from the Kansas City
Chiefs this year and at a point you
could have had them at 12-1 through 13
games with the outcomes of of those
games the cadarius Tony Dro for an
interception in game one you got the msv
uh non interference call uh in Green Bay
the drop pass in Philly with Philly uh
the cadarius Tony lining up off sides uh
and the bills all those games are down
the stretch so you flip a coin there
where they were thoroughly beaten was
the game I called on Christmas day was
against the Raiders I mean they were
they didn't belong in that game at all
Max Crosby owned the Kansas City Chiefs
in that game so I loved how they came
back last week when they were down had
an understanding what they had to do
they shut out the Bengals in the second
half and I think that was meaningful and
they got got their eighth consecutive
division win I love watching Max Crosby
me too I got to see him before the game
we haven't gotten to see each other in
person in a while as you know him and I
have a lot of things in common and I
love him to death and that's the first
thing he did he just came picked me up
and told me he Lov me and did he contact
you when he was going through substance
abuse he didn't contact me personally we
have a a mutual friend because they care
about us who works inside and with the
NFL players and and since that
time you know it's
we've just been there for one another
that's what we do could you imagine have
played in Vegas when you started out not
not with the way if I was who I am now
playing in Vegas it would be amazing
because I would be centrally focused on
what I needed to all that other nonsense
wouldn't exist and I would get all the
great things that come with it what I
love about Darren Waller and what I love
about Max Crosby and so many others that
are gone through some of the things
they've gone to and come out the other
side and are recovering and doing that
in the NFL is that they're still doing
in the Prime of their careers where they
can be great if I would have been able
to find that if I would have been
accepting to what that could be at the
time imagine me being able to play my
Prime with this type of mindset that's
just that's a that's a regret that's
always going to be there now I'm
incredibly grateful and and and amazed
at what this life has given me now at 47
years old but those two in particular um
have just been uh sources of of great
inspiration for me and they're you know
a decade and a half younger than me so
that's that's amazing would you still be
alive if you started out in
Vegas um I don't know I I wasn't a hard
drugs guy though you know I was an
opiate guy and I didn't use when I
played so I didn't use when I played I I
thought competition was my drug of
choice I would go out and binge drink
with the boys and that's how I felt
better about everything but but I never
touched a drug until after I was done I
love to blame that I was a poor
quarterback because I was drugged out
all the time but uh I can't do that I'd
just go with that I might I might it's a
good excuse well if I wasn't a absolute
train wreck but what did it give you the
opid yeah that it it numbed me I was so
sick and tired of feeling but you
couldn't have played football no I I I
know people that have used and they'll
go out and play basketball or I I
couldn't and I also didn't want to waste
it on anybody you know I like a pretty
girl would want to go on a date or
something like that n you know I was
like Gollum from you know the Lord of
the Rings and it was my precious you
know and I was just I was that guy in
the dark blinds closed it was mine and I
didn't want to feel anything that's what
it did for me and I think it's done that
for a lot of people but uh yeah I mean
it's uh it's a it's a terrible disease
and and one that uh that uh had a hold
of me for a while well look at you now
look at me now I'm in the man am I the
only am I the only guy that comes into
the studio anymore uh Chris Sims has
been in here Ross Tucker's been in here
well Ross yeah I mean because he host
your show too yeah uh Sandler was in
here oh
yeah Sandler came in shot Hoops do you
know you remember the story uh was the
Indianapolis the Super Bowl and he was
uh previewing a movie and he grabbed us
and we went That's my boy that's my boy
and that was uh Sierra was in that movie
and uh um we walked into the theater in
the back at the end and he sat next to
me and I was what I was probably a month
away from being arrested for the final
time and I was just still kind of just
teetering on but he like sat there next
to me and he just kept looking at my um
um reactions to it what I laughed at and
everything like that and he talked to me
and it was just so kind and everything I
just that's something I remember I don't
remember a lot of the stuff when I was
going through all that but now he's
finding out you were stoned at the time
so I wasn't stoned at the time I was
counting the seconds that we could get
out of there that I could get back to
the hotel and take my pills that night I
know I was I was doing that so instead
of just absolutely look where you're at
you're sitting next to Adam Sandler
watching one of his movies Dan Patrick
and the Dan ants and everybody like that
who who've cared for you forever and
you're just all you're thinking about is
this so yeah yeah all right we'll come
back we'll talk some college football
also uh coaches you think are safe
coaches you think are going to get fired
in the NFL we'll take a break we'll
continue with Ryan Leaf right after
this Ryan Leaf staying with us college
football NFL analyst for Westwood one
NFL
network has his own TV show the straight
line with Ryan Leaf also travels the
country speaking about substance abuse
mental health his story and his own
words available where you get your
podcast bust the Ryan Leaf story when do
you get to the point where you Embrace
that word Bust or you don't try to fend
it off as much as you used to
um I can use it no one else can so it
pisses me off and I can be resentful and
I can I can point it out because none of
you have any idea but I can use it and
that's what I did I used it for my
benefit um uh that's the way I look at
it I were you a bust um I don't think
any player who has ever been drafted and
played in the NFL is a bust I think the
team made the decision because we had no
saying where we went now if I would have
had the decision and said okay I'm going
to go to San Diego as a second overall
pick um then it's all on me but I didn't
make that decision their choice was to
say that he's the second best
quarterback in the the draft and we're
going to go with him was I more of a
let's say a third round guy I had the
talent probably of a first round guy but
maybe not the mentality of a first round
guy and uh so there's a lot of that goes
into I think that the ability to
evaluate quarterback play uh shifted and
changed a lot with our draft just the
way my mind worked um how they evaluated
it who they talked to um and but they
still you know you still make mistakes
um you just never know on the things
that you and I talked about before how
to quantify what life changing money is
going to do and what failure at the
highest possible level is going to do
but now that nil has been introduced you
are going to get to start to see how
life-changing money may change the
mindset behavior of these young
quarterbacks coming into the league so I
think that will do a do and will go a
long way to help the evaluation process
but do you think getting money sooner is
going to help these players before they
get to you know when they get to the NFL
that they've already gotten a million
dollars yeah I do I think that you're
going to find out I think people are
going to find out pretty quick they're
like you know they're not going to be a
first overall pick if all of a sudden
they were given a million to ion dollar
while they're in college and you know
the Ryan Leaf show happens you know
that's you're not going to be taken with
the first overall pick at that point I
don't care how talented you are um
they're just not willing to take on that
liability and that risk anymore when you
have such talented players available
right behind them what do you think Jim
Harbaugh will do what do you think he
should do I think you and I talked about
this last time I going to show about
what the next step for him is I think if
he wins a national championship I think
he walks out and takes an NFL drop and
looks for the the next thing the the
Super Bowl championship that he's
missing um if they get beat by
Washington which is a real good good
chance that happens um I don't know I
mean it's just seemingly over the last
three years they've been the best team
in the Big 10 and and fallen short every
single time they got over the hump with
Alabama is that the next thing I don't
know I love Jim harba you know as you
know we go way back I want success for
him um but can he have that style that
he has in college can he replicate that
in the NFL yeah he has he's proven it he
but is the NFL going to be the same as
it was when he left the ner I think he I
think he'll be just fine he is a players
coach he because he was just one of the
guys he was a guy that could play almost
into his 40s because he knew what the
locker room was felt like and you've
seen how he's dealt with the players
there talking about how they should be
uh included in Revenue sharing all the
things that has really pissed the NCAA
off and I do think has become a real
Target because of some of the things
that he said he's got the players backs
they love him to death I mean they're
willing to wear free Harbaugh shirts
running around after he's been suspended
for six of the 13 games he's been in
this year is crazy or 14 games so it's I
I think he'll do just fine if if they
were to win a championship I do think he
he he walks and heads to the NFL what do
you do if you're the
Bears I you keep Justin Fields I've I've
been adamant about that ever since the
after the Denver Broncos game and the
Washington commanders game where he
played it lights out then he got hurt
came back and he's played incredibly
well they're going to have a ton a draft
stock they're going to be able to move
that number one pick they probably can
go get find a way to get Marvin Harrison
Jr or who I think the best wide receiver
in the draft is Roman dun and and make a
real difference for this Young
quarterback it's don't don't
stop um before the miracle happens and
that's that's the thing in the NFL a lot
of times you just walk off and you leave
assets at the door when is he a good
enough passer I do think he's a good
enough passer yes I think he's improved
I think he'll continue to improve I
think this offseason the fact that
they're keeping their head coach and
gets he's going to be the guy offensive
coordinator wise that's going to be the
first for him to have back toback so if
you're Matt eberl you're betting your
job Ryan plls the GM you're betting your
job on if you keep Justin fields and it
doesn't go well and you passed on Caleb
Williams or Drake May or Jaden Daniels
you're willing to do that yes and I
don't know if they
are I am I'm willing to to ride with
Justin Fields you're exactly right when
it comes to Ryan poles if he moves off
which I thought he might I thought he
might move off of mat E bro and he might
move off of Justin fields which I think
extends him maybe five more years to do
a rebuild yes so doing this saying Matty
brfl is coming back and the more and
more I hear that they're going to
utilize that number one pick to get a
ton of draft capital and keep the
quarterback that they think could be a
Difference Maker um I I think he does
put his job at Jeopardy and I think
that's good I think there is some
investment I think there's some
desperation and and what that looks like
and they're all tied to it and in
together if they all believe that with
one another if Ryan poles has sat down
with Justin Fields with matd flu say hey
I got your back CU that's what we're
looking for so much as players from
ownership from the front office we want
somebody to have your back and if they
don't believe in you they're not going
to have that and it's just going to be
this up and down thing that that you
playing you cannot be successful you
cannot be a champion uh at that level if
you don't have that kind of uh that
backing how would you feel if you're
Russell Wilson awful awful I you guys
have heard me talk about Russell and
just because of the relationship with
with his mentor and one of my great
mentors after I got out of prison Trevor
moad um and how that affected him and uh
and just to kind
of the narratives are always hilarious
to me uh in the caricature of a person
who's made out to be who they're made
out to be in the media and all this
thing no one ever really knows at all
but the fact that a guy that's making
$250 $230 million uh is a sympathetic
figure in what has played out out is is
a is a a bit hilarious to me because um
yeah it sucks you know they wanted him
to take a cut into his payche and do
something differently uh or they were
going to you know sit him down and Shan
pyton and him don't seem to see eye to
eye and people thinking mat you know
stm's going to be just the same I I I I
think that Russell Wilson's still an
elite quarterback uh I think he can play
it's just a matter where the system is
and where he goes and who knows where he
goes next but okay but let's say he said
to management all right restructure
this why not do that I think that would
have been calling their Bluff and yes
that's what I would have done yeah I'd
be like all right I'm going to
restructure we go whatever you need
whatever you need I Want To Be A
Champion here with you let's do it um
and I think they all looked each other
in the in the meeting and went no we're
good we but how does Shawn Payton Take
This Job knowing that he's got that
contract there with a quarterback that
he may not like I mean I don't know what
the hell Shawn Payton's doing I mean he
he wanted the Chargers job and it didn't
come over yeah cuz then you got your
Justin Herbert you're ready to go yeah
and you're in La everything's then all
of a sudden you go okay you got Russ
don't have you know a first round draft
pick and you now now you don't have a
second because they traded away for you
Sean Payton too yeah that's right you
know so I just don't know why he took
that job I don't know why he took the
job other than to get paid a bunch of
money yeah but he was going to get paid
he was going to get 15 million or
whatever it's going to be he'd get that
but I I just don't know why you'd go
into a situation where you knew that
that quarterback is locked up for a long
time yeah I'm not a big fan of sea
Payton I used to be I don't know why
that shifted I just think some of the
things that he's done this year and I
actually stuck up for him a few times
because I thought it was benefiting Russ
but but he's yelling in your face that
doesn't normally happen with a head
coach and your star can you imagine in
my Heyday if he would have done that no
you wouldn't have done well oh no well I
would have done fine he would have been
buried under Mile High Stadium is what
would have happened there i' give Russ
Wilson a ton of credit you would have
gone spre well on yeah I that dude would
have been PJ car L was asked out right
and it I couldn't believe that on
Thanksgiving and the only game it's the
only game everybody's watching I know
you know it's the only one on TV and
he's berading this man here uh after
just I don't what we heard maybe been
that Russ didn't take enough time for
him to an analyze to see whether he
should have challenged a couple of those
plays whatever your job as a coach don't
take it out on the quarterback at that
point you know do that in private I
loved Russ's response as he just took it
um you know and respect but yeah it's
been a it's been a rough year you always
you always find out the most about
people when they have to go through the
the most arduous and adverse conditions
of of anything Ryan Leaf here in studio
Westwood One analyst also NFL Network um
you're still high on Michael penck Jor I
mean am I the first one really I mean I
think I mean had you heard much about
him when I when I came on the show show
and said I would have taken him one
overall I think in last year's draft he
would have been one of the top two
quarterbacks taken um would you do you
think Pennock would have been over Bryce
young I think he I I don't know if he
would have if I was doing the the work
then yeah I've been high on him for two
years now he's been the best quarterback
in all college football for two
consecutive why why is nobody else on
this bandwagon he's probably fourth or
fifth inju the injuries from Indiana
yeah and I'm like well he's gone and
played what almost 30 games in the last
two years
injuryf free and and what it feels like
Bo Nicks had more momentum and I just
don't than Michael Pennock Jr yeah I
I've been on the uh you know I about I
about got uh I think murdered by LSU
people before the Heisman um because I
was so adamant about how Michael pck Jr
was the the Heisman Trophy winner this
year okay and uh um he's just been the
best leader and where I think it
translates the NFL level the best is
because of what kayin bore and
uh and Ryan grub do offensively it is
very Pro style it is um if if you line
it up to what you see the best offenses
in pro football right now they're very
similar in terms of Leverage numbers and
he's had the wide receivers that he's
going to deal with at the next level too
guys that are Elite um those wide
receivers but I've never seen a player I
don't know how long maybe since Joe
burrow with those receivers being as
accurate down the field as Michael penx
Jr has been this year those passes that
go forward 50 yards down the field it's
like he couldn't have placed it if he
ran up to the guy and put it in his
hands better than what it looked like
against Texas and what strikes me is so
ironic is this is the first time a lot
of people in the entire country watched
him play and they're just like what he's
been that guy for the last two years he
has been that guy he'll continue to be
that guy and whoever gets him at the
next level is going to have a heck of a
franchise quarterback I do believe that
well we're lazy we watch highlights I
always tell people watch an entire game
with a quarterback cuz then you're going
to get a truer sense of highs and lows
interception what do you do after that
you got sacked what do you do after that
you you make something happen whatever
it is that's when you get a true sense
of a quarterback and Leadership and
intangibles all of those things when you
watch the highlights it's easy to go God
that guy is unbelievable that's what
that's what I think in the broadcasting
world and being an analyst is uh set me
up for Success I've watched every single
snap of every n game this year everyone
and I know there are other guys that are
like that that sounds like punishment I
think it's not it's so much fun come on
it's absolutely the funnest thing in the
world and what NFL uh plus has been able
to do with the condensed game 40 minutes
of just to play and then none of the
nonsense of the guys talking on the on
the TV about it I I think that's been a
GameChanger for me in terms of how I
have become an analyst and I think will
be sustainable for me to be able to do
it for a long time because of that and
my little baby girl who's four weeks old
just sleeps on on my chest you remember
the sports you remember three men and a
little baby yeah and Tom celic is
reading the Sports Illustrated to the
baby but doing it in the voice uh of
like how you talk to babies and they're
like what are you reading to her it's
like he's talking about the big uh
heavyweight fight that a guy knocks his
tooth out or bloodies him up she's like
you got to read that to her she doesn't
understand I'm just doing it in the
right voice so I'm laying Clayborn on my
chest there I Anna's watching and I'm
watching the Washington uh Texas game
and I'm doing the the color commentary
but I'm doing it in the voice
and I just see this little girl just
looking up at me like and I just thought
about that and I I said I'm pretty lucky
I'm pretty lucky
guy uh but she likes to show up to he
herb street though that's the weird
thing about that you know it's your
daughter it puts her to sleep yeah she
wow yeah wow yeah that works better
college quarterback you or herb Street
um I'll go herb Street
probably really Ohio State right isn't
that better than Washington State that's
what everybody tells us oh here we go
okay all right a little pity
party nobody likes the Cougars hey pack
two two hey pack two I think we're you
know I'm putting this out there right
now Apple buy us I'll be your I'll be
your color commentary all right let's do
it you could be the commissioner I think
you can't do worse I could do worse I
don't know I was the commissioner of a
fantasy football league in a prison cell
so that's wait you ran you ran fantasy
in prison yeah
okay I think my name was just on it oh
it got me extra Ramen every week I think
is what it was okay yeah all right it
was all about hustling in there you know
all about hustling yeah take your word
for it yep college football NFL analy
Westwood won and uh our favorite uh Ryan
Leaf NFL Network and he'll be on the
call you have the division onea or FBS
whatever the damns FCS so it's Montana
yep South Dakota State yep it's it's the
jack rabbits and The Grizzlies I love it
yeah all right so that's Sunday that is
Sunday up against the NFL games of
course uh we'll we'll win that battle
easy um why not Saturday I don't know I
haven't questioned it but maybe when I
get to Frisco here in the next day or
two Frisco Texas Frisco Texas I will ask
that question I'm like why not on
Saturday yeah nice Saturday early
afternoon yeah early afternoon before
the late kickoff of the NFL yeah yeah
yeah maybe we can change it maybe you
and I I I'll do my
do my and then we can confuse Grizzly
people and maybe they'll miss it
completely uh you know uh and not not
get a chance to hear me call it grizzly
people are not very happy that I'm
calling this game you you're from
Montana but I'm a Cats fan oh Montana
State mon State oh so they're not happy
about it supposed to be unbiased I will
be unbiased but they don't think I will
did they recruit you they did okay yeah
maybe that you turned them down well
they had a great they had the greatest
quarterback in college football history
that came out of Montana Dave Dickinson
they didn't need me seriously guys's
College Football Hall Famer Walter pton
Award winner went up and won a great cup
in the CFL dude is and he grew up a
block away from me and was my hero
growing up so yeah I'm I'm a I'm a big
fan of Montana quarterbacks but uh the
fact that I get to call National
Championship that'll be good it's a
Resume Builder it is how many people get
to call National Championships Dan I'm
going to uh tune in and just try to read
into your bias there there won't be any
be a little bit there all right uh we'll
take a break last call for phone calls
what we learn what's in store tomorrow